bonsoir thomas vous êtes à washington et
les partisans de joe biden ont convergé
en masse vers la maison blanche
oui plusieurs milliers de personnes
rassemblées depuis plusieurs heures
maintenant à quelques mètres de la
maison blanche sous le voyez derrière
moi il ya du monde encore à cette heure
si certains sont déjà en train de partir
mais c'était effectivement la joie ici
dans les rues de washington on entend
assez régulièrement de la musique on
voit des personnes en train de danser et
de scander des slogans et finalement le
sentiment c'est évidemment la joie mais
aussi une forme de soulagement c'est ce
que nous confiait certains par certaines
personnes qui sont présentes ici
soulagement déjà parce que pour eux qui
sont supporters de joe biden quatre ans
de mandat de donald trump ont été
éprouvants c'est ce qu'ils nous ont
expliqués mais aussi soulagement parce
que cela fait maintenant quatre jours
qu'ils ont les yeux rivés sur leur poste
de télévision à regarder les différentes
cartes qui sont diffusées par les médias
américains ou savez vous avez ces états
qui basculent du rouge au bleu du bleu
au rouge
le suspense a donc pris fin ce matin
avec le décompte en pennsylvanie qui a
permis de donner un avantage l'ex à joba
y donne un avantage en tout cas qui ne
permet pas à donald trump de le
rattraper dans cet état saluer octroie
donc vingt grands électeurs et lui
permet d'atteindre les 270 grands
électeurs propose d'écouter les
réactions des américains donc recueilli
ces dernières heures
évidemment du côté de des partisans joe
biden on est très contents du côté des
partisans donald trump
on est forcément un peu déçu je suis
tellement contente qu'on puisse tourner
la page et oublier l'intimidation
l'irrespect l'énergie négative de
l'administration actuelle
série mercy une femme noire kamala
harris carrément elle ne peut pas se
trouver à chaque je ne suis pas choqué
mais je suis déçu et saad khan sein
c'est préoccupant je ne sais pas si
l'élection est légitime et juste joe
biden avait pris la parole hier vendredi
soir donc heure locale ici aux
etats-unis n'est pas plus proclamé
vainqueur à l'époque parce que les
chiffres n'étaient pas officielles
notamment dans l'état de pennsylvanie
mais il va prendre à nouveau la parole
ce samedi soir ce sera donc un 20h heure
américaine 2 heures du matin pour ce qui
concerne leur française
il devrait donc sauf surprise ceux
proclamés en tant que vainqueur de cette
élection il ya déjà publié quelques
messages sur les réseaux sociaux
regardez ce qu'a posté donc joe biden ya
quelques heures sur twitter ainsi que sa
colistière kamala harris amérique je
suis honoré que vous m'ayez choisi pour
diriger notre grand pays
le travail qui nous attend sera
difficile mais je vous promets ceci je
serai le président de tous les
américains
que vous ayez voté pour moi ou non je
garderai la fois que vous avez placée en
moi cette élection est bien plus que joe
biden ou moi il s'agit de l'âme de
l'amérique et de notre volonté de lutter
pour elle nous avons beaucoup de travail
devant nous commençons et donald trump
lui n'est pas présent actuellement à la
maison blanche thomas
non donald trump n'est pas à la maison
blanche il est en train de jouer au golf
en tout cas il était en train de jouer
au golf au moment où les médias
américains ont annoncé la victoire de
son concurrent
joe biden il ya déjà des images qui
circulent du moment où les médias ont
fait cette annonce est donc on voit
donald trump à côté de sa voiturette de
golf
on sait que de toute façon le locataire
de la maison blanche ne concède pas sa
défaite pour le moment il a publié un
communiqué très peu de temps après
l'annoncé par les médias américains de
la victoire de joe biden lors de ce
scrutin il ne reconnaît donc pas la
victoire de son concurrent qu'il faut
qu'ils accusent de proclamer un peu trop
rapidement sa victoire en ecosse nous
savons tous pourquoi joe biden se
précipitent pour ce faire passer à tort
pour le vainqueur et pourquoi ses alliés
médiatiques font tant d'efforts pour
l'aider
ils ne veulent pas que la vérité soit
dévoilé le simple fait est que cette
élection est loin d'être terminée joe
biden a été certifié vainqueur d'aucun
état et encore moins d'un des états très
contesté qui se dirige vers un
recomptage obligatoire qui pourrait
déterminer le vainqueur final on sait
que donald trump est prêt à s'engager
sur le terrain judiciaire pour contester
la légalité du dépouillement et du vote
dans un certain nombre d'états il a déjà
fait savoir cela par le passé qu'il
était même prêt à saisir à la cour
suprême ce qui va être intéressant à
suivre à partir de maintenant ce sont
déjà les dépouillements qui sont en
cours dans d'autres états il ya quelques
instants les médias américains ont
actualisé leur chiffre en ce qui
concerne le nevada dans cet état-là joe
biden serait également en tête plus joe
biden aura de la vence sur le décompte
total des grands électeurs plus ce sera
difficile pour les équipes de donald
trump de contester l'issue de ce scrutin
ce sera donc à observée très
attentivement il faudra aussi observer
l'attitude des élus républicains s'ils
soutiennent encore donald trump dans sa
démarche de contestation du scrutin ou
s'il concède la défaite on a par exemple
mitt romney l'ancien candidat à la
présidence qui a tout à l'heure reconnu
la victoire de joe biden merci beaucoup
thomas pour toutes ces précisions thomas
bonnin en direct de washington